Oh Sam I don't love what I got I'm
joined with my brother Hamid head job
and we're going to be sharing some
thoughts on this individual who has been
active for the longest time
his name is cp4 Schwartz calls himself
the Christian Prince I don't even know
if that name is too fitting and we're
going to get into that in a bit and
she'll law as you guys can see we got
this nice little image down here if what
I think is more fitting but yeah
Christian pringles is more fitting in my
opinion Hamid's please what why are we
even doing this up here why are we
discussing this guy well I mean recently
I had a debate with last doctor last
school day and Norway and after that
debate I was collecting some feedback on
my social media to see what other people
who have in who have kind of branded
themselves for the most part as
Islamophobic or I've shown resistance or
pretty you know critiqued Islam I should
debate next so so I put some people on
the on the list measured Nawaz came as
number one I challenged him to a debate
because of the sheer number of people
that wanted me to debate him all right I
think 12 twelfth or something like that
that voted ten or twelve thousand I
can't remember six thousand almost six
thousand board for measured Noah's we
were left with one of the if not the
least chosen option on Twitter which was
Pringles individual that you've
mentioned who I call Christian boy now
the thing is with him is I didn't know
much about him and I don't know what
about his his content but since some
people did vote for it and I'm guessing
a lot of them are from the Christian
community it's incumbent upon myself to
acquaint myself with the kind of person
he is what kind of arguments it brings
forth and so on so let's take a look at
some of his content and see what kind of
level this guy really is all right let's
let's do that and yeah let's do it
listen up dude I'm not the
I am a scholar you are a donkey you know
nothing you don't not even how to do you
know how to do you know how to eat the
floor answer No yeah okay read for me
that the diverse time reading Arabic
okay yeah I don't have it in front of
screen I'm on phone okay here we go
it is opened over on Monday I got at
speaking the same time the people are
rude
you don't give time to people to talk
you like to talk over each other yeah I
know could I be later value fee do not
be no como la ilahe I mean I'm very
you're a native Arab speaker you've
published in the Arabic language what do
you make of someone who calls himself a
scholar in Islam a scholar in Arabic and
who reads the Quran in that manner I
mean he's not even just trying to get it
from memory a lot of us when we're
trying to get it from memory we can get
it wrong this is his first language this
is his first language can we explain to
that to the to the listeners in to the
viewers what kind of ridiculous reading
that was yeah so off the bat I mean the
first words he screwed up he said yeah I
had little kita up instead of saying
yeah a little cat up and I mean basics
basics of Arabic grammar you don't need
to be an expert in the Quran to know
this the second one he said what do you
say it's embarrassing this is look look
let's be honest
someone who's calling themselves a
scholar someone who's calling themselves
a scholar in Islam oh and all the Arabic
language for him to make a mistake like
this I'm not talking about the matter
one kamon me there and all of these
things or the fact I said let AHA you
and it's meant to be let terrible it's
simply that he does not know how to do
Tami's distinguishing between a fatwa a
bomb on a caesura
and printed diacritical printed script
this guy is a low-level low level
low-level underwire why are we bringing
this guy why are the Christian community
convinced that this I mean is anyone
with a broken except nowadays is the
assumption that he is actually good at
the language that he claims to speak at
in speak n0z don't know any better
that's just a thing
that's so let's carry on this is there's
there's a there's a bit more to this
because yeah yeah my mind I was like
maybe maybe his English is better than
his Arabic I don't know so here's here's
a bit of that the same verse says read
with me carefully say not Trinity the
same verse the same verse says Trinity
is a must all the people of the book go
make know execute in your religion nor
say Allah or wicked so he could speak
English because he was really it was
excesses and he read it excuses I mean
this is embarrassing isn't it he can't
speak I mean why would you sorry to say
I mean if you really want the acoustic
community and if you really want to
elect someone you know to be your
representative I mean to be honest with
you David word for all of his lack of
knowledge and areas he was a professor
he was a PhD he knew how to communicate
he you know he knew how to speak in a
language with proficiency so why does
this guy who I heard also attacks David
Wood after the debate with me cool de
magellan things like that why was
someone like that I was an individual
like that be your next choice to go
against I think they're just looking for
anyone else to be honest and he's been
active for a while and you know I like
what he does is he he runs the show I
mean you know in his in his platform he
runs her show he's he speaks over people
he you know you know when you have the
mic when you have the mic people see you
assume that you're in the position of
strength and superiority reality you're
just controlling you're just controlling
the show who is Allah as a rock man who
is a Rahim he is he is God he's telling
on I'm telling what himself wasn't worth
his conserve as a 3 or 1
he's that he's the gracious God that is
it he is a three Oh
first let me know this is this is why
people think this is why his fan base
thinks that this guy is actually good at
what he does
he speaks it over his audience invites
them advice because the show speaks over
them mutes them now we're gonna see some
more racy some more
check this out guys just to show you how
we stupid the Muslims are that those who
install the core set up shut up shut up
those who install their parents should
be put to death this is the doctor just
get lost
okay so you get lost coward you said
Paul is a fake person he never met Jesus
correct
let me get you busted just yet you liar
filthy who insult Paul because they are
ignorant when Paul in the Quran is a
Messenger of God
the secret I just like to point out this
guy and he before before you've been
getting to this we weren't even getting
to his claim this guy's muting the
person who's asking a question man this
is this is and I think they want he
wants you to come on this platform you
know it's like the first time I've heard
of this verse you know you know when
that happens
oh yeah carefully everybody read with me
carefully chapter 36 verse number 14 let
us see what they say Paul he never met
Jesus Paul is not even he's a fabricator
Paul but there
not only that he made miracles all right
chapter all right so that's very
important huh what he just said he said
that but it says the Quran says that
Paul performed miracles in the name of
Jesus and that this isn't the Quran this
is supposedly in the class what's wrong
with him what's wrong with this liar I
mean did he actually provided a
reference person just go to chapter 36
verse 14 where does it say Paul where
does it say that he performed miracles
for the sick I mean it's a serious thing
is this a serious thing I can't believe
just this guy's this guy's I mean is he
a liar I mean I mean I've seen I've seen
multiple examples of him saying this is
what this verse says you go to it's not
there it's his life so he's a liar so
he's like a verbal message flat-out lies
with his audience respect is all issues
why would you I mean the thing is do you
not think that people are gonna open up
the book and check no no no most people
don't most people job so your arguments
are gonna have superficial
superficiality on it because his fanbase
will eat anything that he says you know
they'll eat up anything he says and to
him butts what that's what's important
care about the Muslims are gonna look it
up he cares about his Christian fanbase
growing and them believing what he says
so so let's go on let's see what he says
he's quoting gum tipsy Durban Cathedral
it says narrated that the following
irrigations of the three messengers from
Wahab evening should a man from shore ie
algebra the names of the first two
messengers were Simone and Johanna and
the name of the third was Poros and the
city it was in charge why you idiot
you keep insulting Paul when the Quran
and your scholars report him as a
messenger of Jesus and in the same time
he says the course I plan our scholars
what the hell is wrong with this
individual
this is the thing when you go to Bhutan
kuttappan you have no understanding
what's going on
this guy's a fool he said the Prophet
where does the boy say Colorado sort of
lifestyle and what did it say so it said
it says sure I named el jabbo okay which
he miss reads as a B is like an hibari
who's who's like disregarded who's not
seen as an authority and who has some
you know opinions about matters that
have to do with a healthy table and
whatnot he's not someone who's taken
seriously and however Kristen Prince is
saying that our prophet says this man
that he may be his prophet may be his
prophet is called sure agent Abadi
this guy's a lie is a joke is a joke
this you've lost your credibility after
that your academic critical you only
have one chart you make you can make
mistakes and then you have to retract
them as an academic oh no we didn't talk
for long all right so what do you think
about what was saying about Sam for
students scholars like you because we
don't know the Arabic so that's true
that's the true comment that's you can't
this guy some sure mone enough students
yet we're doing the best we can by the
grace of Jesus Christ you know alright
so if he is calling him a scholar he
sees him as an authority him and David
would must see him as an affray ro if
you guys see that kind of scholar no
wonder why David would was dealt that
decisive blow in that debate no wonder
why David would was dealt like the size
of God and because you guys are such
your guys are you guys apologetics
against Islamic Christian community is
on such a low level that someone who
can't even read the Koran you guys think
because you got a sick
so you guys think because he has a thick
accent in Arabic that he can speak
Arabic but he can't speak of it but we
saw we saw just been he can't pronounce
names he can't even read from the Quran
that must have let alone from memory
this guy is nothing this guy's nothing
this is the best you can offer the
Western world it's just the best you can
offer as an apologetics against Islam
trust me man the challenge of Islam is
going to be something new for you guys
the next 20 or 30 years you're gonna see
two things you're gonna see you gonna
see if this is the case
Christiana is going to continue
depreciating and it's going to go into
two directions mostly in the atheistic
direction but it's gonna be a big chunk
of people let's eat that is the option
Islam is the option is the is the
monotheistic option that takes you away
from the Trinity attention away from all
these things that you have a long line
of messengers and prophets all that came
with one belief which is to believe one
God and that fine finalized people can
see that as the option not this nonsense
sorry to say apologetics against the
slap the guy's a liar
he can't even reference properly when he
references chapter 36 verse 14 it says
Paul is in it he's a liar
of course you're gonna of course you're
gonna fail when you debate people like
us of course you're gonna fail of course
you're gonna fail and you're gonna
continue failing we got we got a bit
more we got a bit more it's a cover by
the way yeah let's let's go through this
and show almost under what the what
about the Inquisition the Spanish
Inquisition I agree with it I agree with
if I'm a king I will do it too
because simply you see somebody betray
me
aha an occupation came to my country and
they can they can millions of my people
and they occupy us for hundreds of years
I mean now we are big victorious should
we go after the one who betrayed and
joined the army of the enemy
I mean is it normal why people they
think this is a this is a church thing
it's not your thing but like it was a
very brutal thing they did right likely
to hit people and they burn them alive
kill the Jews as well so this guy's
anti-semitic III would like to point one
thing I think it's really ironic that
the atheists that he's talking to has
moral standards than he does oh there's
no doubt about that but let me just say
something else is that sorry to say
sorry to say this guy if a Muslim has
said the same thing that in that Muslim
would be written off because how can you
not only just to find the Spanish
Inquisition
yeah which as whoever the brother he's
not Muslim is he that the Atheist there
was that individual who was pointing out
is brutal there was torture but it's not
only torture there was all kinds of
things I mean there was forced
conversions there was forced immigration
I mean anyone can look at that part of
history he was right Jews at that time
had migrated to Muslim lands he's saying
the Jews took their side therefore they
deserve the torture basically he's he is
because of his because of his extremist
meat this guy's an extremist this guy is
actually he he represents an extremist
in the Christian community just like we
have extremists now kamini we saw the
London Bridge attack well bro this is an
extremist in our community sorry to say
he's basically saying what happened
there it's fine this guy's despicable
man this guy's finished what does this
guy want from me well the only thing
he's gonna get from me it's Baba hella
we do mubahala and then straight after
will see the results of a paella in the
cage
this guy's anti-semite he don't like
Jews he just said it Shia Muslims he's
basically everyone should be against
this guy's Muslim Jews and Christians I
don't even know why the hell am i
dealing with this extremist do you think
I'm gonna be dealing with an extremist
like that the Christian community should
be the first to condemn this individual
they should be the first just like we
have to condemn the London Bridge attack
and so on and so forth this guy is dirty
man no God if you don't stop I will
force you to open the camera and show me
how I know this is the nicosia are you
there sigh let me - so hey are you there
hello
I don't hear you don't keep the mic from
your you know don't do breast feeding
now later now let us see what Whitney
kathira said about the Mota I think she
is doing breast feeding right now taking
a break always always stay with you I
will stay with you tomorrow
I will stay with you until tomorrow we
will keep our keep I will make you read
the whole page if we find if we find in
the same page or even from it says this
is about the same listen listen listen
if we see in the same is the same page
hold on hold on if we read together in
the same page or even from we will read
to all of it if we find there it says
that this is about meta do you promise
me to do breast feeding for me yes maybe
marry she will join us okay no problem
that's Kim - yes she said yes she said
yes
Marriott marry the cook you will join us
no problem continues marry me first okay
okay marry Dakota Mew and so you would
do breastfeeding for me no problem
okay continue continue continue continue
I cannot wait for my breastfeed and you
promised me everybody is a witness okay
it's mean you don't give me your boobs
you don't take off your panty and you
know what
even if you are the only women in the
world I will not do breast feeding for
when you from us come back you mister
women full of AIDS and now I wanted to
focus with me we arrived to the Mota
finally you will give you will give me
your breast you like it or not - promise
boys - now admit you say it you say you
promise you promise if you can see
you're saying this is about Mota you
will do breast Julia for me everybody
heard you okay just tell me that right
now was gonna show her face very geez I
don't know you are a [__] like your
prophet and this why you are allowed
yourself to be modest or the scumbag
like your prophet I can go to the
English right now do you want me to
switch you are trying to run away from
doing breast feeding from you were
why is that man what this guy's this
guy's dirty
this guy's a pervert this guy goes
you're gonna do it whether you like or
not or something like that
this is raped this is rape this finished
sorry to say he's finished after that
man he's done what he wants to come and
speak to us I've never seen anything
I've never seen anything like that and
this is not a representation of
Christianity and this is not a
representation of the Christian
community this guy
believe me after just hearing that now
the Christian community are gonna disown
him I have full trust I have full trust
because I've met members of the
Christian to me I don't know very well
they're gonna say this man does not
represent anything does not represent
the Christian teachings there's not
represent Jesus do you think Jesus would
speak to a woman like that according to
the New Testament corpus according to
the Scriptures according to their
scriptures do you think that Jesus will
come and talk to a woman and till I take
off your panties I'm gonna breastfeed
you and all this kind of things
no you cannot you cannot you cannot
justify this behavior under any
circumstances
and you wanna come on a platform with me
and you wanna come and speak to me and
you want me to lower myself and talk to
you you're a dirty brother you're a
dirty guy man
you're a dirty individual you're a sicko
you're a sicko and that's why you're not
gonna come and show your face to someone
like me that's why you'd never come and
stand face to face with someone like me
that's why you're scared of the Muslim
community
well not only that probably the
Christian community as well you're
coming out speaking to the Muslim women
are [__] prostitutes would you like
someone to say that to your mum to your
sister to your to your auntie you're
dirty you're dirty and I know you've got
sexual thoughts that are not a permit
you can't even control your sexual
desires or you talk about as food and
sex ro you are out of control
you're out of control talking to a woman
like that you're dirty you're dirty
you're dirty
you're finished you're finished well I
you're finished talking about women work
like that coming to section what the
hell
you're a dirty man you're a dirty man
and you're meant to be some kind of
public figure for the Christian
community yo man I was following with
the Christian community you may not have
tens of thousands of people following
you how dare you
Alec and the any appear to be honest
when I saw when I saw other clips I just
thought that he was someone who was low
but when I saw this clip this specific
clip I was against any Muslim debating
him I don't think it's not it's not it's
not for me you know that's for the
Christian community I know for my
experience a vast majority of Christians
are not yeah are not anything like that
and they would not endorse anything and
we have to be fair there for me debating
this guy what do drama does he want me
to come on his little platform so they
can mute me yes women being prostitutes
what you talk about my mum and my sister
and my and my daughters and all that you
wouldn't come and say that to me face to
face Europe you know what you are yeah
you had come to say that to me face to
face because you know what you are yeah
you wouldn't come and say that to man to
man face to face but behind the little
screen you're a keyboard warrior you're
nothing you're boy you're a boy but you
know what with I would want to end this
discussion yeah with one of a message of
solidarity yeah and hope because what I
want to say is look we might have a the
Koran says like home do you know
commodity yeah
you have your religion and we have our
religion like you know if we don't agree
on your religion Oh Creed it doesn't
mean that we can start abusing each
other it doesn't mean that now hate has
to fill the environment you have to that
you have to that you have to contribute
to a poisonous environment know if you
know if you really don't understand the
meaning of peace and solidarity look
somehow look at the Quranic discourse
well in I did Harun holder for example
or Allah Kathryn Cather
whenever allah subhanaw taala he says to
a comb to a group of people are harm
their brother x right so obviously these
people weren't muslim muslim yet they
know they were not muslim yet
however lost potala he said to these
group of people aha whom can together
yeah to these group of people their
Brava was sent who is ex-wives area so
at the end of the day
AHA whom we are brothers and sisters and
here for example in London in in in
yeah we're not brothers at Dean and
sisters be no we're brothers in humanik
were brothers in in tribe like at the
end of the day I was born here I was
born here you know in in London
we're western muslims at the end of the
day and we feel like we have solidarity
with the people in this country we feel
like we'll protect a Muslim or Christian
or a Jew from physical and verbal abuse
we don't tolerate physical and verbal
abuse the like which we saw in London
London Bridge attack like that we don't
tolerate that you know and that's the
problem I saw some says he then Lemuria
there yeah tell Jenna whoever kills my
had there was a noncombatant
non-believer couldn't learning this is
an interpretation of it if someone is
not most Atman and someone who is would
you call it he says that includes a most
Atman and a my Adam and then me so every
kind of noncombatant non-believer we
says whoever tries to attack them and
kill them they will never smell the
fragrance of heaven therefore we say as
muslims we come together with the
non-muslim community the Jews and the
Christian and we won also and condemned
these individuals a rogue black sheep
trap individuals in our community what
we want is the Christian community to
also do the same for its community to
flush out those elements which are
extreme frankly man this guy is an
extremist and I'm gonna say that my
understanding of the word
he's extremely yeah he's extremely
vulgar
he's extremely abusive he's using rape
jargon and he's justifying historical
genocides it gets not only Muslims about
Jews how can we as Muslims Christians
and Jews not condemned that as well we
have to condemn all of it and you know
at the end of the day that's how we can
enhance solidarity within different
community
inshallah we can have the religious
discussion but it doesn't have to reach
that level where we're fighting each
other killing each other or of course
abusing each other on on the Internet
this is cyberbullying ya know and I
bought a freak out here there's like a
lot higher in regards to Christian
Prince there seems to be a thirst for
refutations personally I'm not gonna go
out of my way to create like thorough
reputations well I will do though what I
yeah will do I will try to satisfy that
thirst by providing examples of the guy
having absolutely no knowledge yes I
will provide some examples of him
flat-out lying and shall I'll be
uploading those on my channel on
response so yes I love ya we can we we
can link that in description or
something so we you know because the end
of the day is good that's coming from
you your native Arab you've published an
Arabic language
you've specialized in some other areas
of knowledge and with him you're gonna
easily eat this guy up you know well I
don't think that video is really
effective to the extent whereby you need
to spend too much of your time on it
like I said not plan a thing just just
just show his a complete incompetence
and charge the people having any last
thoughts know what I said really
alright alright boys hope you guys
enjoyed the show okay take care of
yourself
you guys take care take care of
yourselves as well and inshallah we'll
see you guys in the next one said I'm
really cool I wore a condom